[Music]
we all love eating chocolates but what
if you're gifted cocoa beans instead
can we really relish the cocoa beans
just like chocolate of course not
similarly there are so many organisms
which require a few important
constituents but they are not present in
the utilizable form one such example is
that of nitrogen yes atmospheric
nitrogen is extremely important for the
proper functioning of cells the main
reason for that is that proteins are
made up of amino acids which are in turn
made up of nitrogen molecules also many
other compounds important for the cell
are made up of nitrogen so are we saying
that nitrogen is required by all
organisms of course yes but we can't
really breathe nitrogen from the air so
this problem will be fixed by the plants
for us yes they will synthesize
compounds having nitrogen and when we
consume plants the nitrogen will enter
our body simple isn't it actually not
problem of nitrogen consumption by
animals got solved but what about the
problem of nitrogen consumption by
plants nitrogen is present in abundance
in the atmosphere however the divalent
molecule has a very strong triple bond
shared between its atoms and it's very
difficult to break this bond it requires
extremely high amounts of energy one
instance occurring naturally is the
lightening process which helps break the
two atoms apart but that doesn't always
help
so the problem still exists even plants
cannot take in nitrogen directly from
the air so now who will solve this
problem we don't need to worry plants
also seek the help of some other
organisms the microorganisms yes several
bacteria and blue-green algae are a part
of this activity this important process
is referred to as nitrogen fixation
what do we exactly mean by this the term
fixation refers to converting an element
into its usable form so are we saying
that these organisms convert nitrogen
into utilizable forms absolutely these
organisms are referred to as nitrogen
fixing organisms these nitrogen fixers
present in soil convert the atmospheric
nitrogen molecules into compounds like
nitrates nitrites and ammonium these
compounds are then taken up by the roots
of the plants and then the plants uses
these compounds to synthesize their own
proteins consumption of these plants by
animals and humans then gets the
nitrogen into the animal kingdom this is
how the process of nitrogen fixation
occurs let me quickly recap what we
learnt
humans need nitrogen but they can't take
it directly from the atmosphere hence
they get it from the plants but even
plants can't take it directly from the
atmosphere this is where the nitrogen
fixing organisms come into the picture
they convert the atmospheric nitrogen
into consumable compounds for the plants
and then animals consume the plants to
get this nitrogen but wait if all the
nitrogen in the atmosphere is gradually
fixed by these microbes and used by
plants and us then it would deplete
right what if it gets entirely depleted
what will happen then how will organisms
survive
guess what nature as always holds a
secret solution to this and that secret
is the nitrogen cycle yes the nitrogen
in the atmosphere is brought into the
biological world where it is utilized
but it is also sent back to the
atmosphere by some means this process of
cyclic flow of nitrogen from the
atmosphere to the living world and back
into the atmosphere is called as the
nitrogen cycle but how does this cycle
actually flow let's have a look as we
know the atmospheric nitrogen is fixed
in
major ways firstly by the Rhizobium
bacteria living in root nodules of the
leguminous plants and secondly by
nitrogen-fixing bacteria and blue-green
algae in the soil
the first type involves fixing of
nitrogen exclusively for legumes the
roots of these plants have nodules that
are small bead like structures these
nodules are the homes for a group of
nitrogen fixing bacteria called the
Rhizobium the roots can thus directly
get benefited due to the activity of
these bacteria but what about the non
leguminous plants we don't need to worry
we have the second method the nitrogen
fixing bacteria in the soil and the
blue-green algae help in converting the
atmospheric nitrogen into usable
compounds these compounds will be
absorbed by the plants and utilized
further now when animals consume these
plants the nitrogen enters their body
now how will the nitrogen get back into
the atmosphere from here definitely not
by breathing let me give you a hint have
you come across the process of
decomposition yes that's the answer to
this question when these organisms die
their bodies get buried in the soil
now here the decomposers are all set
into the action the decomposers help to
break down the various compounds
containing nitrogen so what will be the
result yes it results in releasing the
nitrogen trapped inside the organisms
body back into the soil amazing isn't it
but wait here's something more
interesting the soil also has another
category of bacteria called the D
nitrifying bacteria what could they be
useful for as the name says they will
help release the nitrogen molecules from
these compounds present in soil into the
atmosphere yes these denitrifying
bacteria sometimes convert the available
nitrogen containing compounds from the
soil to release molecular nitrogen that
means they do not really wait for the
decomp
was us to complete the process whenever
these denitrifying bacteria encountered
the nitrogen containing compounds they
simply converted and release molecular
nitrogen a keen look at the complete
process gives us an understanding that
the entire process flows in a cyclic
manner this is how several types of
bacteria help in ecologically important
processes like nitrogen fixation
[Music]
you